hey youtubers is Charlie so for my bonus
Marvel movie video this week we have to
talk about the death of shield as it
applies to Captain America 3 as well as
the plot of Avengers age of Ultron
because Kevin Feige if she said this
really interesting thing in a recent
interview he talked about how they
really wanted the Avengers to face this
new threat you know
Ultron of course without the benefit of
a giant international organization like
shield so the cool thing is is that
Marvel has already done a story like
that and it's called Secret Avengers
real quick though if you are finding me
for the first time normally I do bonus
Marvel movie videos on Tuesdays be sure
to subscribe to get everything and feel
free to leave me suggestions for future
topics in the comments below so here we
go
the big question we need to ask in this
video is what happens to Captain America
and the Avengers when there is no more
shield first we have to talk about the
end of Winter Soldier Chris Evans and
Nick Fury said two very important things
well they actually said the same thing
essentially they're going to conduct new
missions on their own off the grid Nick
Fury took off to try to track down the
remnants of Hydra and Captain America
kind of did the same thing but also is
kind of looking for the Winter Soldier
to try and rebuild Tatom so in addition
we have Maria Hill at Stark Industries
and Sharon Carter at the CIA this
mirrors some of the things that happen
in the comics in the wake of the Civil
War storyline after which Norman Osborn
took over shield and rebranded it hammer
then came dark Avengers and then Secret
Avengers which is what we're talking
about now Secret Avengers is really
about Captain America putting his own
team together to go on covert missions
you know like a spin-off of The Avengers
but here's where things get really
interesting as it applies to the plot of
Captain America 3 or potential plot the
first Secret Avengers team he assembled
included beast war machine Valkyrie Moon
Knight Nova Black Widow Sharon Carter
and ant-man so right off the bat we have
to toss out beasts because Fox copyright
and they haven't introduced Valkyrie in
the movie universe yet but she could
always be replaced by SIF since she's
also Asgardian moon night isn't really
someone that we've met in the movies yet
either but Nova could always come via
guardians of the galaxy and the other
members we've all either met or will
meet before Captain America is released
you know ak8 ant-man so the second big
question we have to ask is if they
actually did Secret Avengers for the
story of Captain America 3 what would
the real team
like because in practice they're not
gonna cast all those roles remember the
movie is going to come right after
ant-man in 2016 so we'll have guardians
of the galaxy Avengers 2 and ant-man so
there will be a lot of new characters
and potential stories but let's talk
roster and here's the rule Captain
America can only pick from existing
Avengers and the other characters that
we've met on-screen based on the
original team here's what we might see
Don Cheadle is warmachine jamie
alexander is SIF someone from the Nova
Corps in guardians of the galaxy
Scarlett Johansson is Black Widow Emily
VanCamp and Sharon Carter and Paul Rudd
as ant-man so now let's get a little bit
more realistic and kind of shorten that
list just a little bit because if they
cast all those people it would feel like
an Avengers movie and this is really a
Captain America movie so it's gonna be a
little bit smaller so let's just take
Black Widow Sharon Carter and Lady SIF
wouldn't that totally be crazy Captain
America and a badass team of Marvel
women it would be like Charlie's Angels
Marvel style I don't think they're gonna
do that but fun to imagine I'd actually
swapped SIF for Paul Rudd just to
balance it out so now let's talk plot in
Secret Avengers there are a lot of
different villains but eventually we
kind of get to masters of evil and I
think that in the movie universe we will
see a form of them at some point there
are actually two volumes of The Secret
Avengers comic but in general since
Captain America is very earth-based
I think any of the characters or story
arcs they pull out will be more like
Winter Soldier you know more Bourne
Identity than spaceships and aliens like
some of the other Marvel movies so the
big takeaway from all the blowback after
Winter Soldier is is that Captain
America will be putting his own team
together and going on missions to deal
with you know Hydra masters of evil and
possibly whatever Nick Fury ends up
getting tied in because remember he went
off on missions of his own make fury is
actually a big part of the story and
Secret Avengers so if you want to learn
more about that just read the comic but
let's move on to what this all means for
Avengers 2 because like I said Marvel
implied that shield would be on extended
smoke break whatever Ultron comes so the
good thing about this is is that we
already know a lot about what's going on
in the movie and who the big characters
are we even saw Captain America and
Hawkeye's new suits and Iron Man's new
armor we even know what Ultron looks
like but the destruction of shield opens
up a lot of possibilities for how the
story will progress so if they decided
to stick with The Secret Avengers plot
it'll be Captain America traveling
around the world
to get them all back together and if it
wasn't clear after Thor the dark world
Thor is actually living on earth right
now in addition the Avengers tower will
be finished so that will be a focal
point in the movie we got to see a
little peek of it during Winter Soldier
it was a real quick shot this means the
real problem won't be making them all
play nice together
it'll be finding the resources to fight
Ultron if only there were a billionaire
industrialist playboy philanthropist
nearby who just happened to hire shields
former second-in-command oh wait that
was Maria Hill at the end of Winter
Soldier they totally did that so they
will have all of Iron Man's resources at
their disposal which is pretty cool a
lot of fun toys but if Ultron is capable
of co-opting electrical systems we need
to think about how that's going to
affect all the stark tech so it's
possible that Ultron could start
controlling some of the Iron Man suits
and then there's the Bertha vision
that's a whole other thing
even though Ultron created vision in the
comics we don't know if the movies gonna
do it that way if they're gonna change
his backstory there's also all the
tesseract energy we don't know if that's
gonna play a role if you didn't catch
the Baron von Strucker reference at the
end of Winter Soldier in that post
credits scene
Loki's staff and tesseract energy were
responsible for Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch getting their powers
remember all those Fox copyright issues
with both the characters being used they
had to change the backstory so it's a
little weird but I have a feeling that
the creation of Ultron and vision will
have something to do with tesseract
energy you know as well as kind of the
interaction with stark tech here's the
big question that you should all try to
answer in the comments below how is
Stark Industries going to step in and
fill the shield void you know provide
that support system to fight Ultron you
know is it just gonna be stark tech or
is it going to be something else
something new in slightly related news
because it is Wednesday I'm also doing
an arrow bonus video so that's mostly
gonna be about the finale as well as the
flash crossover next week be sure to
subscribe to get that I'm actually gonna
be adding it as an annotation right here
you can click here all added as soon as
I post the video and you can click here
to get my Winter Soldier review thank
you so much for watching
hail Hydra I'll see you guys later
you